THANKFULLY, NO FATALITIES HAVE
BEEN REPORTED.
>> Julie: TO MILLIONS OF
PEOPLE ARE TRAVELING FOR
THANKSGIVING, DESPITE GOVERNMENT
OFFICIALS URGING THEM TO STAY
HOME AMID FEARS WITH CASES
SKYROCKETING NATIONWIDE.
THE HEALTH CARE SYSTEM COULD BE
OVERWHELMED IN THE NEXT TWO
WEEKS, EXPERTS SAY.
DR. MARTY MAKARY IS A PHYSICIAN
AND PROFESSOR OF PUBLIC HEALTH
AT JOHNS HOPKINS AND FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR.
DR.DOCTOR, GREAT TO SEE IT
INFECTIOUS RESEARCHER AT THE
MEDICAL UNIVERSITY OF
SOUTH CAROLINA SAYS, AND I’M
QUOTING, "I’M A LITTLE BIT
CONCERNED WE MIGHT START SEEING
THINGS ON THE SCALE OF WHAT WE
SAW EARLIER THIS YEAR IN PLACES
LIKE CHINA AND SPAIN AND ITALY."
COULD THINGS GET THAT BAD
FOLLOWING THANKSGIVING, DO YOU
BELIEVE?
>> I THINK WE WILL SEE A SERIES
OF ROLLING INCREASES.
THE TREND IS NOT A GOOD TREND.
I DON’T THINK WE HAVE TO WORRY
ABOUT A MASS SPIKE WITH
RATIONING OF THE DOORSTEPS OF
OUR HOSPITALS LIKE WE WERE
CONCERNED ABOUT BACK DURING THE
DAYS OF NEW YORK, MARCH AND
APRIL.
PEOPLE NEED TO TAKE THIS VERY
SERIOUSLY.
90,000 AMERICANS RIGHT NOW,
TODAY, JULIE, ARE IN A HOSPITAL
BECAUSE THEY ARE HAVING TROUBLE
BREATHING OR ARE IN VERY SERIOUS
CONDITION BECAUSE OF COVID.
WE ARE ADDING, AS YOU SAID,
ABOUT 170,000 NEW CASES A DAY.
BUT WE ARE ONLY DIAGNOSING ABOUT
ONE IN FIVE TO ONE IN TEN.
THAT’S ABOUT A MILLION NEW
INFECTIONS PER DAY.
PEOPLE DO YOU NEED TO
PRECAUTIONS.
>> Julie: THE LINES AT TEST
SITES ALSO INCREASINGLY LONG,
AND IT TAKES LONGER NOW FOR LAB
RESULTS TO COME BACK.
THE TESTS PEOPLE USE TO GET BACK
IN ABOUT 2-3 DAYS ARE NOW TAKING
UP TO FIVE.
THAT IS GOING TO COMPLICATE
THINGS AS WE SEE RATES OF CASES
SKYROCKET.
THE DELAYS IN GETTING THOSE
RESULTS BACK IS ALSO AN ISSUE.
HOW MUCH SHOULD PEOPLE HEED THIS
WARNING THEN TO STAY HOME,
CONSIDERING, IF YOU ARE EXPOSED,
YOUR TEST RESULTS ARE NOW
DELAYED THE SAME WAY THEY WERE
BACK IN THE SPRING OF 2020?
>> EVERYONE NEEDS TO ASSESS
THEIR OWN PERSONAL RISK.
WE KNEW THIS INFECTION HAD ITS
DEATH OR MORTALITY SKEWED TOWARD
COMORBIDITY BUT WE DIDN’T
REALIZE JUST HOW SKEWED IT WAS.
IN FACT, WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
THOSE WITH ADVANCED AGE BEING AT
INCREASED RISK, IT’S BECAUSE
ADVANCED AGE IS LINEAR OR
COLLINEAR WITH COMORBIDITY.
TESTING IS STRAINED, BUT WE
DON’T WANT TO BE REQUIRING EVERY
BASKETBALL PLAYER TO HAVE TWO
TESTS IN ORDER TO PLAY.
THOSE ARE THE LIFESTYLE TESTING
THINGS THAT ARE CLOGGING UP THE
SYSTEM RIGHT NOW.
>> Julie: THERE ARE A LOT OF
COMPANIES TESTING EMPLOYEES
THREE TIMES A WEEK.
I KNOW SEVERAL OTHERS IN THE
PRODUCTION BUSINESS THAT ARE
HAVING MESS.
MY QUESTION, MIGHT WE BE SEEING
THE SAME HOLIDAY-DRIVEN SPIKES
IN DECEMBER AND INTO JANUARY?
THIS MAY BE JUST THE BEGINNING.
COMING UP WE ARE GOING TO BE
CELEBRATING CHRISTMAS, HANUKKAH,
KWANZAA, NEW YEAR’S, AND THAT
VACCINE, BY THE WAY, THE
PRESIDENT HAS SAID THE WARP
SPEED VACCINE IS SUPPOSED TO BE
COMING OUT SOMETIME POSSIBLY BY
THE NEW YEAR, AND SOME EXPERTS
HAVE SAID THIS COULD BE WIPED
OUT BY MAY.
DOES ANY OF THIS SEEM REALISTIC
TO YOU?
>> FIRST OF ALL, I THINK IT’S
IMPORTANT NOT TO HAVE ONE SINGLE
BLANKET RECOMMENDATION FOR
THANKSGIVING OR CHRISTMAS.
OUR CONCERN IS WHEN PEOPLE ARE
NOT TAKING PRECAUTIONS, AND THEY
ARE HIGH RISK.
WHEN WE WERE TELLING PEOPLE AT
THE MEDICAL COMMUNITY TO WASH
THEIR HANDS LIKE CRAZY, WE
PROBABLY SHOULD HAVE BEEN
TELLING THEM TO WEAR MASKS.
WHEN WE TOLD PEOPLE TO STAY AT
HOME, WE PROBABLY SHOULD HAVE
SAID TO AVOID INDOOR CONGREGANT
SETTINGS.
OUR STRATEGY NEEDS TO EVOLVE.
WE ARE LIKELY TO SEE INCREASES
IN PEOPLE WHO ARE SORT OF IN
DENIAL, MAYBE BECAUSE OF THE
MIXED MESSAGING AND THE DELAYED
CLINICAL SCIENCE, BUT I THINK
PEOPLE NEED TO ASSESS THEIR OWN
INDIVIDUAL RISK.
THE VACCINE IS VERY GOOD NEWS.
WE WERE TOLD IT IS 95% EFFECTIVE
IN PREVENTING THE INFECTION, BUT
WHAT PEOPLE DON’T REALIZE IS SO
FAR THE VACCINE TRIALS ARE
SHOWING THEY ARE 100% EFFECTIVE
IN PREVENTING DEATHS FROM COVID.
THAT’S GOOD NEWS.
I THINK WE ARE ON TRACK FOR
MARCH, APRIL, AND MADE TO BE THE
MONTHS OF MASS VACCINATION IN
THE UNITED STATES.